es sind wiederkehrende orte über die wir
sprechen wenn wir über missbrauch an
kindern berichten es sind orte wie
campingplätze und kleingartenanlagen
kann dahinter so etwas wie ein muster
stehen darüber wollen wir jetzt sprechen
mit dem profiler marc hofmann bei mir
jetzt hier im studio ganz herzlich
willkommen herr hofmann
man hat das gefühl dass diese orte
kleingartenanlagen campingplätze strände
dass das irgendwie die orte sind an den
misshandlungen geschehen ist das
subjektiv und falsch aus ihrer profi
sicht ja es ist nicht ganz falsch aber
auch nicht ganz richtig was sind die
zwei hot spots bei kindesmissbrauch
erstens inter familiär
also es ist nicht der fremde täter nicht
die dunkle gestalt aus dem park die die
kinder entführt sondern es ist er das
nahe umfeld die eltern sind statistisch
gesehen die gefährlichsten personen für
ein kind das sage ich immer wieder dass
der onkel der stiefvater die mutter der
vater das sind die typischen täter und
die familie hotspot nummer eins direkt
danach kommen andere institutionen die
ebenfalls zu dem direkten umfeld zu
zählen sind also sporteinrichtungen
bildungseinrichtung und andere
institutionen das kann kann das kloster
sein dass jungen internat der
sportverein und auch andere
freizeiteinrichtungen
das heißt die täter suchen sich schon
stellen aus an denen sie leicht an
kinder ran kommen und er so in
persönlich privaten bereich der
sportverein oder auch der campingplatz
sind durchaus nicht untypische orte
ob jetzt aber campingplätze in ganz
speziellen und auch im vergleich zu
sportvereinen oder familien
ob das jetzt noch ein besonderer hotspot
ist das ist mir so nicht bekannt und da
würde ich auch camper jetzt nicht unter
generalverdacht stellen ja aber das ist
doch das schockierende was sie sagen
dass die eltern eigentlich die
gefährlichsten personen sind das
missbrauch im rahmen der familie
stattfindet und das müsste doch
eigentlich der bereich in unserer
gesellschaft sein der am besten
ich sag mal kontrolliert überwacht wird
nämlich uns selber durch uns unsere
familienmitglieder
warum kann dann trotzdem missbrauch in
dieser engen gemeinschaft in der engsten
gemeinschaft unserer gesellschaft
überhaupt passieren ja die familie
kontrollieren kann eigentlich nur die
familie selbst und das ist genau das
problem die eltern haben ja die aufgabe
ein kind zu schützen zu fragen ist ja
was passiert hatte ich jemand angefasst
aber was ist wenn die eltern täter sind
das ist auch für kinder die die
schlimmste situation weil natürlich
lieben es ihre eltern trotzdem
und wenn aber die person die man am
meisten liebt zum täter wird dann ist
das natürlich etwas was kinder innerlich
zerreißt und oft viele jahre später
schlimm schlimmer traumata auslöst das
ist ein riesenproblem denn wie kann man
wie kann man dagegen vorgehen kinder
machen selbst keine anzeige ja wenn das
gesamte umfeld mit drin steckt dann wird
es doch sehr sehr schwierig trotzdem
muss man aber mal sagen bei
kindesmissbrauch ist das dunkelfeld noch
viel größer als das was uns bekannt wird
und ich waren immer ein bisschen davor
mir fällt auf wenn ich die letzten fälle
betrachte lichte münster solingen es ist
immer nrw jetzt könnte man ja sagen und
das ist falsch
irgendwie gibt es in nrw ein großes
großes kinderschänder problem aber der
zusammenhang ist eher andersrum man muss
mit dieser kriminalstatistik sehr
vorsichtig sein denn ich will mal ein
beispiel geben wie könnte man die
drogenkriminalität im frankfurter
bahnhofsviertel auf null zurückfahren
indem man einfach nicht mehr streife
fährt wenn man nicht mehr kontrolliert
und nicht mehr nach kriminalität sucht
und einfach die augen zumacht nach dem
motto was ich nicht sehe gibt es nicht
dann ist das dunkelfeld natürlich
genauso groß wie vorher auch aber
plötzlich ist die drogenkriminalität
zurückgegangen in amerika auch durchaus
ein beliebter trick um bestimmte
statistiken aufzupolieren man sucht
einfach nicht mehr so besonders viel
danach nrw und das hat der innenminister
klar gemacht hat vor einiger zeit doch
beschlossen mehr dagegen zu tun
und je mehr man danach sucht desto mehr
fälle kommen auch ans licht das heißt
wenn in einem bundesland die
kindermissbrauchs rate um zehn prozent
steigt ist das möglicherweise ein
zeichen dass die polizei gut arbeitet
weil sie nämlich mehr danach sucht und
deswegen war ich ein bisschen davor die
polizei zu kritisieren wenn es viele
fälle gibt und sie zu loben wenn
wenig fälle gibt dann oft ist der
zusammenhang eher andersrum
je mehr sie nach kriminalität suchen und
in diesen bereichen ermitteln desto mehr
fälle kommen ans licht
deswegen glaube ich nicht dass in nrw es
besonders für kindesmissbrauch gibt ich
kann mir aber durchaus vorstellen dass
in nrw besonders gut und gründlich in
den letzten monaten danach gesucht wurde
zum glück und beim suchen beim aufdecken
dieser fälle ist ganzen nummer eins und
ganz wichtig und ganz weit vorne an der
front das jugendamt das ist der erste
ansprechpartner würde ich jetzt sagen
wenn es probleme in familien gibt sind
jugendämter und kann man das so pauschal
beantworten gut darin missbrauch zu
erkennen in familien in die sie
reingehen weil das ist ja auch ein
problem auch der berichterstattung
es wird ganz häufig gesagt ja das
jugendamt hatte ja schon kontakt mit
diesen eltern warum passierte da nicht
im rahmen ihrer möglichkeiten sind die
schon gut die haben nur auf viel zu
wenig geld und ein großes problem ist
der mangel an zentralisierung
sie sagten gerade das jugendamt ist dann
zuständig so klar ist aber für einzelne
personen gar nicht wer zuständig ist
stellen sich eine ganz konkrete
situation vor kind kommt aus der kita
erzählt geschichten die eltern doch
sorgen bereiten oder sie wollen eine
anzeige machen
oft werden sie von einer stelle zur
nächsten geschickt es gibt nicht so die
eine anlaufstelle sondern es gibt ganz
viele und dieser mangel an
zentralisierung ist ein riesenproblem
denn oft ist es so stellen sich vor sie
hören immer wieder über denselben
sportverein über dieselbe person eine
beschwerde noch eine beschwerde noch
eine beschwerde noch eine beschwerde
irgendwann ist es offensichtlich dass es
hier in muster ist aber das erkennt man
nur dann wenn alle diese beschwerden
auch an dieselbe stelle kommen und da
gibt es oft multiple beratungsstellen
sowohl vom staat als auch privat und
ehrenamtlich und eine nummer pro
bundesland wäre eigentlich wünschenswert
meinetwegen auch drei aber einige wenige
zentrale anlaufstellen wo diese fälle
auch gebündelt werden das könnte helfen
täter zu überführen denn oft ist es so
dass zwei einzelne meldungen sind beide
zu schwach sie reichen nicht wenn der
durchsuchung aber wenn man all diese
fälle bündeln würde wäre der
anfangsverdacht begründet das heißt
zentralisierung ist einer der punkte wie
viel helfen können meiner kommunikation
zwischen den behörden auch sie als
profiler sie versetzen sich auch in die
täter versuchen zu denken
nachzuvollziehen wie die täter denken
wenn sie jetzt schauen auf die
diskussion über das verschärfte strafmaß
für kindesmissbrauch für den besitz und
die verbreitung von kinderpornografie
löst das etwas bei potenziellen tätern
aus die diese neigungen haben die diese
krankheit haben
oder lässt sie das komplett kalt ist
natürlich sagen krankheit ist es schon
es ist eine psychische störung des gilt
als sexuelle präferenz störung aber wir
sind nicht für das verantwortlich worauf
wir stehen was uns gefällt aber durchaus
für unsere taten deswegen das wort
krankheit impliziert immer so ein
bisschen indirekt naja wenn die krank
sind können ja nichts dafür sehr wohl
pädophilie dafür können sie erst mal
nichts aber es gibt in berlin keinen
täter werden es gibt da anlaufstellen
von männern die sagen ich spüre da was
in mir was mir selbst angst macht ich
würde nie danach google nie täter werden
und ich will mir hilfe suchen das ist
sehr ehrenwert die die täter werden
kinderschänder sind für ihre taten sehr
wohl verantwortlich und kinderschänder
zu sein ist keine krankheit das ist eine
sehr bewusste und oft mit maximaler
skrupellosigkeit getroffene entscheidung
jetzt gerade der letzte fall in münster
gekühlte serverräume 500 terabyte wir
reden nicht über leute die den problem
haben was sie nicht im griff kriegen
sondern um absolut skrupellose
kriminelle und ja da muss man doch
unterscheiden die motivation sie fragten
nach dem nach dem kopf der täter was die
motiviert ich würde zwei wesentliche
typen unterscheiden die einen sind
absolut skrupellos die wissen wie
schlimm das ist was sie tun und die
unternehmen anstrengungen nicht erwischt
zu werden gehen stark net verschlüsseln
ihre telefone speichern keine kontakte
das ist die eine gruppe dann gibt es
eine andere gruppe die hat durchaus
einen gewissen reden sich aber selbst
ein dass das alles in ordnung ist das
heißt oft tarnen sie ihre taten als ich
liebe das kind ja ich streichelte es nur
ein bisschen dem kind gefällt es ja auch
es kommt ja trotzdem noch zu mir
das heißt die missbrauchen ihre
vertrauens unabhängigkeit situation die
sie zu dem kind als eltern oder oder
angehörige oder nahestehende haben und
reden sich selbst ein dass das alles
nicht so schlimm ist das heißt die einen
täuschen ihr gewissen die anderen haben
kein gewissen beides ist gleich schlimm
und höhere strafen immer wieder in der
kriminologie und dass man sich relativ
einig dass bei den meisten delikten
höhere strafen nur bedingt eine
abschreckende wirkung haben
ich kann die argumentation aber nicht
ganz folgen und habe es auch nie getan
denn fakt ist doch folgendes egal ob die
strafen die täter abschrecken
abschrecken oder nicht wenn sie zehn
jahre im gefängnis sind können sie wären
derzeit keine anderen taten begehen
und wenn man sich die letzten fälle
anguckt wir haben über den über den
medien kennt fall eine menge
gesprochenes wo es ja nun einen
tatverdächtigen gibt wir haben über
münster über lüfte gesprochen
und viele der taten hätten ab einem
gewissen punkt verhindert werden können
wenn man früher tätig geworden wäre und
man sieht ja in münster er war bereits
vorbestraft wegen besitz und verbreitung
von kinderpornographie und das hat in
scheinbar nicht abgeschreckt direkt
danach weiterzumachen und ich glaube
hätte er dafür acht oder 15 jahre
bekommen würde das anders aussehen aber
14 monate auf bewährung oder ähnliche
strafen die schrecken definitiv nicht ab